[Música]
desfilaron o esa es la pregunta crucial
que todas las empresas de moda se hacen
actualmente las aglomeraciones están
prohibidas las personalidades actores
cantantes estrellas de internet ya no
quieren tomar el riesgo de viajar en
estas condiciones como seguir
garantizando una comunicación de marca
eficaz para su colección crucero 2021
dior asumió el desafío produciendo un
espectáculo sutil impresionante pero sin
público en el centro de la ciudad de
lecce en la región de pureza en su
recital ya
[Música]
en un momento se trata de un proyecto
relacionado con mis orillas pero es un
proyecto que desarrolle en un momento
particular de nuestra vida no sólo la
mía somos una empresa que trabaja mucho
con el mundo entero razón por la cual
numerosas personas dependen de nuestro
trabajo terminamos lo que era muy
importante para mí era hacer tomar
conciencia sobre el valor del arte
artesano en bullas y cuán importante es
que las nuevas generaciones no lo
pierdan y reinviertan en generaciones
para no perderlo omar que rim decir
encuestó
por ejemplo el tómbolo este trabajo de
encaje de uso nació en el siglo 15 los
dedos anudan tuercen atan los hilos
concentración máxima esta flor más de 15
horas de trabajo
con algunas de mis artesanas aquí en
zona rural decidimos montar una escuela
para enseñar el encaje de uso deteste la
impresión con tarjetas perforadas de fer
y los usos porque es una forma cultural
de nuestro territorio
esta es la pequeña rosa está compuesta
por estas hojas que estoy haciendo y la
rosa tridimensional que se aplica por
encima la naturaleza nos da tanto de
ella el arte del salento las diferentes
iglesias los diferentes monumentos son
tantas ideas que nos inspiran para crear
un cutis entidad cual es void crear un
cuerpo
los usos tintinean alegremente los
telares experimentan un ritmo más
sostenido en el corazón del taller
textil de la fundación de konstantín he
creado en 1982 para enseñar la artesanía
tradicional
entrando en la contención
s
quien ingresa a la fundación recibe un
salario que no se ve en todas partes el
nombre de este laboratorio elegido por
nuestro fundador ayuda sara allí es
amando y cantando lo que creo que hay
que elegir un lugar mágico para vivir yo
lo elegí tal como lo elegimos todas este
lugar cuenta el donde el pasado del
presente y se proyecta hacia el futuro
pensando en otras mujeres
ver su futuro pensando el astrónomo
un desfile es una escenografía luces y
aquí slogans compuestos por la artista
feminista italiana marinela senatore
enaltecidos por luces de la empresa
fratelli especialista en piezas
religiosas
porque me siento un poquitín o me siento
honrado porque me siento un poco de
igual a igual con ellos christian dior
tiene la capacidad de vestir a todas las
mujeres y nosotros tenemos la misma
pasión cuando vestimos las plazas de los
pueblos para las fiestas siempre he
dicho que éramos los diseñadores de las
fiestas de este país siempre porque no
es amo de shati pero con todo igual de
la fiesta del país en cuanto al alma de
la colección maria grazia chiuri se
volcó hacia el artista italiano pietro
rufo tras pasar por las universidades de
arquitectura de roma y columbia en nueva
york concentran sus investigaciones en
las nociones de naturaleza y libertad
el proyecto crucero 2021 fue
desarrollado alrededor de varios temas
en relación con puzzles y ante todo una
serie de flores un campo de flores
todas estas flores que dibujé a mano una
tras otra fueron reunidas para crear una
gran composición que daba la impresión
de un campo colorido con pequeños
insectos libélulas mariposas e incluso
pequeñas arañas
tarántulas que se encontraban en el
campo que quedaron en mente prestado
las tarántulas son el origen de talento
y de su forma más desenfrenada la física
el veneno que inyecta la tarántula sería
capaz de hacer caer en la locura más que
una danza es un ritual hay que ver en
este trance el símbolo de la lucha
contra las dominaciones
es primera linterna para expresar
mediante la música en el marco de este
arco narrativo de 20 minutos a la vez el
desespero y el deseo de poder salir de
esta opresión este grito de dolor
llamémoslo así se volverá poco a poco
una liberación y vencer a un grito de
alegría
creada en los años 20 para las clientas
adineradas que pasaban el invierno bajo
el trópico las colecciones crucero no
están sometidas al ritmo agitado de las
fashion weeks que representan una
bendición financiera incomparable su
duración de vida en almacén es superior
a la de las colecciones prêt à porter
estamos aquí esta noche contra todo
pronóstico y estamos orgullosos del
resultado de esta colección esta noche
había una inmensa emoción en esta plaza
y esperamos hacerles sentir esta misma
ilusión a las clientas que numerosas
miran en directo el programa esperamos
encontrar esta misma emoción en nuestros
almacenes en noviembre
los grupos de lujo han sido resilientes
frente a los efectos de la pandemia pero
también están conmocionados participar
en el renacimiento de las culturas
ancestrales podría a largo plazo reducir
el impacto de la crisis